[Music]
hello
parker just in time
to celebrate celebrate
wait where are the arms
oh wow so cool
but how did you intracranial neural
network
neurotransmission speeds under one
nanosecond
faster than signals travel inside the
brain never mind to an external
prosthesis
we did it peter
no one can take this away from us
i'm amazing hey and your work on the
neural web was the key
but we haven't even tested it yet
there's so much we don't know it works
beautifully
uh come on take a look
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new spider-man tom
holland trailer video i'll explain
what's going on with this
the studio talked about the future of
the spider-man game franchise obviously
this has a lot to do with what's going
on
at sony with the future of spider-man in
the movies in the venom movies
so if you're new to the channel be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos we'll
do a giveaway for the actual game
all you have to do to enter is be a
subscriber and let me know what your
favorite spider-man game
is so just starting with the big stuff
first number five if you didn't see this
morning the team that worked on
spider-man ps4
and who are currently working on
spider-man ps5 right now
said that they decided to change the
character model of peter parker
make him look more like tom hall and
spider-man because of what they're doing
with the future of the game
referring to spider-man ps5 everyone's
been using face app to change his face
and post all kinds of memes this morning
there's one that looks like chris evans
all kinds of other characters
so this is the actual official statement
from the studio that they released on
twitter
they said that today's news about the
new peter parker face model has
surprised some of you and we at
insomniac totally understand your
reaction heck it even took me a while to
get used to peter's new look but as we
discussed the franchise's future and
moving to the ps5
it quickly became apparent that
delivering an even more believable
looking character
made finding a better facial match for
actor yuri lowenthal who's the voice of
peter parker in the games
we all love is peter a necessity we care
as much about his character as your
attachment
to him so please know we didn't make
this decision or change
lightly as we did throughout development
of marvel spider-man we'll continue to
read your comments listen and always be
looking for ways to improve
every facet of the game and at the same
time i hope you can trust
us that this decision is what we feel is
best for the future of the franchise
in our upcoming goals for this beloved
marvel character
so obviously insomniac is teasing just
really really big moves that they're
making with the future of the spider-man
game franchise
talking about spider-man ps5 so if it's
not clear what they've done is is
they've completely
changed spider-man ps4 game and
remastered it for ps5
but now peter parker looks like tom
holland in the entire game
you can get the game for free with the
ultimate edition of the spider-man miles
morales game or they'll also probably be
selling the remastered version of
spider-man ps4 at some point for a
discounted price
in number four naturally everyone saw
how much he looks like tom holland now
and just assume that they're trying to
make the game feel even more like the
movies
spider-man ps4 was already an s-tier
game with a great story to begin with
but now with the ps5 hardware they can
do full-blown ray tracing and everything
looks way more photo-realistic
so of course they want it to feel more
like an actual movie that you're playing
through
no coincidence that venom is a key
component character of spider-man ps5
and tom holland spider-man is going to
be crossing over with tom hardy's venom
after spider-man 3 and venom 2 let there
be carnage
insomniac hasn't revealed exactly when
spider-man ps5 is going to be released
or given a time frame but it's probably
not going to be till at least 2023 or
2024 it's still a ways off so you can
kind of see where i'm going with this
reading between the lines with all this
news there were rumors last year when
marvel and sony were still fighting over
the future of tom hall and spider-man in
the mcu everyone remembers that around
d23
no fears no regrets part of the journey
is the end when that got worked out
there were reports that sony had also
signed tom holland to a new contract
for spider-man movies that also included
all the crossover movies they wanted him
in like the cameo scene that they wanted
him for in venom 2 post-credit scene
number three so the actual full-blown
spider-man vs venom movie where the
whole movie is the two of them together
won't actually happen till after
spider-man 3 and venom 2
giving the spider-man ps5 people time to
finish the game and release it so that
they're doing spider-man vs venom in the
game
around the same time that tom holland
spider-man is going up against tom
hardy's venom
remember that sony owns the spider-man
character in the movies
at least the rights to spider-man but
they also bought the game studio
insomniac
that makes the spider-man ps4 and
spider-man ps5 game
so sony controls all of this
spider-man's story going on in the games
and in the movies
so of course they would also probably
want the spider-man in the game to look
more like their spider-man
in the movies in moving into more
spider-man venom action if you've been
paying attention to what they've been
doing with venom in the movies he's not
supposed to be a villain he's supposed
to be an anti-hero so why would
spider-man be fighting him for an entire
movie
to make as many avengers jokes as
possible the real endgame for spider-man
and venom is maximum carnage which is
why i think that they made the title of
venom 2
let there be carnage which kind of
sounds like a weird title so that they
could do
spider-man and venom together and they
can call that movie spider-man
maximum carnage just like the title of
the comic book that they're ripping the
story from
in that comic book story spider-man was
forced to team up with venom who he'd
been fighting for a long time in order
to stop the threat of an even
worse character carnage so that becomes
sort of sony's version of captain
america civil war where they hype it up
like spider-man's gonna be fighting
venom
but the real story is them teaming up to
stop carnage
just like in captain america civil war
where they hyped it up is team
cap versus team iron man but really it
was all about stopping baron zemo
number two and bringing back around to
the spiderman ps5 game
yes venom is a villain for the most part
but harry osborne venom that they're
teasing here in the spiderman ps4 post
credits scene gives you an idea for how
this arc is going to play out
harry is peter's friend so even though
they'll wind up fighting each other
probably because it's a video game
the real villain in this trio of
characters here is the norman osborne
green goblin
they're just creating this tragic arc
for all these characters to make it feel
more dramatic
green goblin uses the venom symbiote to
save his son harry but
accidentally causes him to go crazy
until spider-man can help harry osborne
but in the process of that norman
osborne goes
full-blown green goblin himself going
off the rails and spider-man and harry
osborn venom
have to team up in some way to try and
stop him they kind of reference this at
the end of spider-man ps4 where norman
osborne starts to gaslight
dr octopus claiming that he's never
going to admit any faults in anything
that happened during the course of the
game in the serum that they were working
on
that will just continue until he goes
full blown green goblin
the truth okay
the truth is you were only ever worth a
damn
when you worked for me the truth is
you could never accept that i'm better
than you
you're a failure otto and you always
will be
he wasn't really the main villain of
spider-man ps4 that was meant to be dr
octopus but really you can see what's
going on here they were just teasing him
as an even
bigger villain that would pay off in
sequels so number one bringing back
around to the movies right now there are
still all the spider-man stuff happening
in the morbius movie that's still being
released in march next year
thankfully no more delays for spider-man
movies right now
spider-man 3 is coming out in december
next year and venom 2 is still coming
out in june
the morbius movie will be the first
major spider-man crossover stuff going
on with the venomverse
movies at sony it's not a full-blown tom
holland crossover with him appearing on
screen or anything like that there is
supposed to be a j jonah jameson cameo
with him coming back after the
spider-man far from home post-credit
scene to scream about how terrible
spider-man is and how he's ruining
society
then they have all the sinister six
stuff that they're setting up with the
vulture in that prison
in the actual pictures of spider-man's
costume appearing
and those are just meant to lay the
groundwork for bigger crossover in venom
2 like a post-credits scene cameo
maybe some more sinister 6 teasers in
spider-man 3 because they keep
introducing different sinister 6
characters in the mcu
then after that they actually do the big
venom spider-man crossover movie in the
sinister six movie
which right now based on what the sony
people and amy pascal are saying are two
completely separate ideas like they want
to get venom and spider-man in a
crossover
per kevin feige but all the other sony
people like amy pascal are talking about
doing a big sinister six movie but they
keep talking about those
in two different ways like they're two
completely different movies
i don't know what their plans are for
venom when it comes to sinister six
we'll have to wait for venom two to see
if they do more sinister six teasers in
that movie
but let me know in the comments if they
do spider-man vs the sinister six do you
actually want venom to cameo in that
movie
or do you just want them to save that
crossover for maximum
carnage and live-action spider-man into
the spider-verse potentially
that would kind of be like sony's
version of avengers infinity war and
avengers end game
live-action spider-verse but post all
your predictions in the comments below
of course i'll do more spider-man 3
videos when they start filming that
movie later this year we'll start to get
more teasers and find out what's
actually going on with that movie we
know a little bit about it already
everyone click here for my spider-man
into the spider-verse 2
trailer video and easter eggs and click
here for that brand new avengers 1
division trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight